we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p uh here is a voicemail from a
u.s marine who wants to know
why do republicans use us as props
very interesting take a listen
hey david uh this is uh matt big fan of
the show
so the question i wanted to ask you is
when it comes to uh support and kind of
uh
bowing your chest about being patriotic
a lot of politicians
will use the military as props
um i'm i'm a marine myself
and uh and i and i see uh people talking
about how trump just loves the military
because he'll do these very superficial
things
like uh like hug the american flag and
talk about how brave the troops are and
stuff like that
and my question is do you what do you
think it is about uh
the military polling uh so well with
republicans when
they uh they so they so very obviously
use it uh use us
as a prop and the democrats aren't uh
innocent of it but it feels like the
republicans do it
a lot more uh thanks david excellent
voicemail so
first of all let's take this piece by
piece the things
trump does for the military are sort of
like i got a voicemail a couple weeks
ago from
some trump is saying david you're jewish
why don't you love what trump has done
trump's great for the jews he loves
israel
and he moved the embassy and blah blah
blah and i had to explain
american jews are very liberal and
nothing that trump has done helps get a
peace deal done which for me as an
american jew and
it's a foreign policy uh uh issue i want
to see a peace deal
and moving the embassy from tel aviv to
jerusalem does nothing it's just
it's it's optics and posturing and it's
the exact same thing
with the military so it then you get to
the
interesting question which is why does
the why do republicans and trump pull so
well among the military so there's a
couple different things going on there
at the base level more republicans are
joining the military
okay so it's not that the military
makes people republicans although i'm
sure that that happens to some degree
it's that you have an organization that
attracts more
republicans which is why you see the
military tend to support more
republicans than democrats in the
presidential race however
this year the republican numbers among
the military are the worst they've been
i don't know how long but for a very
long time check out the recent
military times poll so important to
understand a bunch of different things
but what's important is that you
are identifying that the things donald
trump does
are meaningless they are not really
supporting the troops much like george w
bush
sending troops into an optional war for
fake reasons
was not supportive of the troops
supportive would be let's not send them
into harm's way
and i'm glad you're recognizing that i
hope more of your
your military colleagues will we have a
great bonus show for you today i had the
opportunity
last night to take advantage of some of
the prepping i had done
i had a situation come up yesterday
where i was prepared
thanks to my prepping it didn't go so
well i will tell you why
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com